America is the heart of wokism and it's  infected London and London is just so  woke I lost all my friends in London  like they don't like me I posted  something about Roe versus Wade And the  fact it was overturned because a lot of  women kept saying they're forcing us to  have children no they're not supposed to  get pregnant we're just saying like if  you don't have kids then you know close  your leg and I I tweeted something like  that and a lot of girls that I went to  school with they DM me saying I'm  embarrassed to know you've gone too far  you're a terrible person Miami offers a  lot of amazing other things like-minded  people freedom-minded people  entrepreneurship you know keeping fit  going on a bike ride enjoying the  weather the sea so it offers that